you mentioned in the book that you need
to learn to love your mistakes and
even as I was telling you about my my
hopeless uh or or not hopeless but
hapless uh Tendencies there's a part of
me I start to flush I start to feel
embarrassed it's like it's a little bit
shameful and I can't see that's that's
that's not a helpful attitude you know
it's uh our society raises children and
so on so much with that way like they go
to school they're taught to be shameful
about their mistakes and the star is the
person who gets all of the things right
and so on and that's almost one of the
reasons that a lot of times children in
schools are not the same who Excel or
not the same people who are selling life
and so when you look at that it's the
opposite like
if you're if you know and you're
confident then you know you can't learn
I mean how do you improve when you have
to be believe that you're perfect all
the time
it just doesn't make sense
so and there are things that I won't do
because I'm like no I'm just not going
to be that good at that and so it's a
very it's a very destructive attitude
yeah and the thing that you can realize
is
that you can almost do anything if
you can do it with somebody who's also
good at it
so there are things that you're
naturally going to be good at and not
perhaps for example you may be very
creative
bot very scattered
okay
yeah which is very much how Wright is I
think probably tend to be okay so there
you are okay and that's why I'm saying
then you work with somebody
who is you know very not scattered and
they can use your CR so you get the best
you can get your creativity and you can
get the other so many people make the
mistake of thinking that they have to be
good at stuff oh I have to learn the
thing that I don't know how to do well
no no you don't really need to do that
you just need to find somebody it's
gonna do it well with you